i just need to make the actual content to everyone else inaccessible so how do i kind of do that
well cookie bombing okay yeah my man uses cookie bombing that's what i'm talking about
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
hey what's up y'all before we dive into the episode i wanted to tell you a little bit about
the sponsor which is appropriately app omni i worked at app omni for four and a half years
before leaving to do full-time bug bounty in this podcast and our guest of this episode aaron costello
is currently working there app omni is the best sas security for the enterprise product
on the market they do everything from taking audit logs and using those events in order to
normalize them and enrich them and then send alerts basically downstream to the companies to the to
the security operations team they also have specific insights which are basically like a security expert
in your pocket like a sas expert in your pocket there is policies which you can use to monitor the
systems configurations and settings across all of your sas in a single place there's another feature
called ask omni which is the ai feature that i built over the course of last year which allows
you to chat in natural language with all of your sas security data points whether it is your policies
or your alerts or what have you and it comes up with like really nice graphs and heat maps and stuff
like that as well if you're interested if you're a stakeholder if you're you know a cso at a big at a
big org and you're interested in um upping your sas security game you can reach out to app omni
at app omni.com a p p o m n i dot com thanks back to the show me and aaron were at a um at an event for
app omni and it was it was me and him and then our manager at the time for labs his name is alec
and alec is like ex-military obsessed with fitness like he literally like runs cold plunges does bjj like
every day oh my gosh and we were just looking around all the vendors like yeah i think we could take any of
them yeah me and alec we could take anybody any any booth in the in the building that's pretty funny
that's great man yeah dude it i don't know there's something about i feel like there's a higher
percentage of people in security that are actually just totally ripped too like is that is that my if
is that just my impression because there's like you know there's that stigma going around of like
the 400 pound hacker in their mom's basement or whatever but i'm like most of the hackers i know are
like actually pretty ripped yeah i will say it's probably because at least in the bug bounty space
everyone's really high agency right i mean everybody's working really hard they learn a ton
they go dominate their field so they're probably also dominating their health in a lot of ways
yeah yeah yeah for sure man all right cool so let's get let's let's get back on track aaron um thanks so
much for joining us on the pod man um the way we do it here on the critical thinking podcast is we bring
on a guest we say their name aaron costello uh and we say hey man show us a bug so what what what bug
did you bring for us today yeah so today i'll be talking about a bug that i found god very late 2020
early 2021 most likely the latter and it's combining your sas based misconfig because we'll be talking a
lot about sas security today and also more traditional kind of web hacking uh some kind of janky browser
behaviors um so right off the bat um for a private program on on hacker one um the travel company
that had a uh one of the subdomains was running on salesforce so it was built entirely on salesforce
and integrated with salesforce um platform in that way so navigating to the site it was mostly
unauthenticated access and they had this functionality that would allow for one of their customers to upload
uh documents and detail a support request right so talking about issues with passport flights or anything
like that sure um and then based off the kinds of uh things that they were saying on that form i thought
okay some of these attachments could be sensitive like oh make sure your id is clear that kind of thing
um so i uploaded a basic blank image random text i was trafficking uh all of it through through burp
and what i noticed was the actual image was being uploaded to an external um booker provider which is very
very very unusual because salesforce has its own storage for for images and documents right okay yeah
and how i was actually doing this was using apex and we'll get to that later on that's from salesforce
nomenclature but apex is like server-side code on the platform so it's kind of java syntax it's an object
oriented or intended programming language and so in the actual request itself when i sent those details
uh if one of the parameters being provided was a path and the response was a url of the image and
also along with that a a key to access the image on this book it so you navigate to the url you get access
by removing the key from the url in the external storage bucket you no longer have access okay okay so
it's like signed access sort of thing exactly exactly so i was kind of playing around with it and tested out
some couple things so i i managed to validate okay yeah i could replace another user's like file if i
wanted to right but then again the actual file names were randomized so unlikely um i was also able to
traverse the path so in the request i was able to modify the path that was being uploaded to the bucket
um once again potentially writing as a directory of writing sensitive files that kind of thing
but we need to know names of these files right now one key thing that i noticed was there wasn't really
any file uh file type validation being performed and i couldn't execute any like server side right
because it's a bucket yeah right um but i could upload things like html svg xml uh that kind of stuff
um just nothing server side so using a technique that i actually read from i think it was file descriptor
um which is about app cache manifests okay so i'm gonna have to lock in for this one man
and i feel like a lot of the newer book companies won't know what this is because it
app cache manifests were pretty much replaced by service workers but the the what i was able to do
was i could upload an app cache manifest and additional html files and so how the the app cache manifests
work is it's a special file type and it's used for um providing the ability that for users to access
content offline on a website so it stores the content of a page in your browser so the manifest defines um
what what content is effectively cached in your browser so there's an interesting attribute
within this app cache manifest called a fallback
so any file in that same directory um or sorry every user's files uploaded in the same directory
and so the app cache manifest would apply to every file in the directory and so the fallback what it
specifies is a path to a file in that directory that is requested if
the other files become inaccessible so right so using the technique from file descriptor what i was able
to do was i uploaded one file that was specified as the fallback and this is a html file that would
exfiltrate um the the url so when the fallback redirects this file it would exfiltrate where it was
being redirected from to my own web server ah and that was the path of the in the key exactly right
i'd grab that key i just needed to make the actual content to everyone else inaccessible so how do i
kind of do that well cookie bombing okay yeah my man uses cookie bombing that's what i'm talking about
very very underrated so i was able to upload a html file that's specified at the beginning
use this manifest and then proceed to just fill the browser with like junk cookies and so when that
happens when the cookies become too large the content becomes inaccessible in the browser
so the actual attack vector here or theoretically what it would be is you would upload these files set the
stage and when a support engineer goes to view that file it would load the manifest it would basically
dosh their browser and they'd think okay so like what's what's going on here i don't know what's
happening maybe the file's corrupted or something so they'd go to view another case and look at their
files when that file is viewed it would kick in the fallback which points to basically my html that
performs ajax to my my own um externally hosted web server and it would capture that other customer's
signing key dude and so i was i'd be able to access potentially sensitive documents through that um so
that's kind of combining the sas misconfiguration there with your typical exploit and that's why i
found it interesting there is a little bit of user input required there but uh i think it's a nice
little chain it kind of shows what you can do when you're a bit of a jack of all trades in a lot of
yeah yeah no i i love that dude and i love anything that utilizes one i just i freaking love
anything that utilizes cookie bombing man cookie bombing is just such a fun technique and i just am so
like in awe of the fact that that still exists you know like why why do we allow the browser to just
set so many cookies that it freaks out the web server right and and and causes these uh these
mistakes to happen um so i i love it when it's mixed with service worker with app cache and uh the ability
to exfiltrate those those paths in those those keys um is just perfect and combining that you know i was
thinking okay so you know we use this attack on the victim and then when they go and submit a service
request then i'll get access to their files but really the you're right the more impactful thing
is hit the engineer you know that that goes through and is actually triaging each one of these tickets
and then you get access to all of the paths and all of the tickets that they click on that's right
that's exactly it and you know part of that attack and why it wasn't very applicable to other customers
was that once the form was submitted it was like fire and forget so you couldn't actually view
what you just submitted you'd probably get an email in a couple days from a support engineer saying
oh i just received your ticket right so yeah it was is a very very interesting bug um i think it was
classified as as a high um probably being a bit generous there but i think the novelty gave me a
few extra bonus points dude do you think that actually uh this kind of question for both of you
all do you think that if it was loading any kind of like summary images or thumbnails or anything like
that that it could have potentially triggered a bunch on a single page yeah yeah yeah yeah depending
on how the back end was written that's it exactly yeah so they could have been like a restricted area
that's salesforce platform that had like preview thumbnails of all these of all these support
requests and it was just firing off all of them you know so yeah that's sweet dude well uh aaron
now i'll officially do your intro now that we've got a bug under our belt and people know that uh you're
well worth your salt although i can also vouch for you i worked at um at app omni where aaron
currently works with him for three or maybe four years um it's been it's been a long time since we
both worked there together obviously i recently left so i uh left aaron standing uh as the only member
left of the app omni labs team but um i can personally vouch for how uh bright aaron is and i think
that his depth of knowledge and expertise in the sas security space specifically is completely
unparalleled as most bug hunters will know if you've seen his blog so his blog is enumerated.ie
and um specifically there are salesforce and service now misconfigurations that have made
him and others lots of money from bug bounty but more importantly has secured the the data of
probably hundreds of millions of users i know at app omni it's like we check for these things of course
but then lots of bug hunters have reported them on companies that don't use app omni or or other
providers and i'm sure that the other competitors in the sas security space are checking for these
same things so um so yeah so it's a pleasure aaron to interview you and i know that jess and i are both
really excited to to hear your opinions uh specifically let's dive straight into just
misconfigurations in general um you know you and i have talked a lot about this but our listeners maybe
have not thought deeply about it uh what makes misconfiguration such a really um both lucrative and just
like neat thing for bug hunters to look for yeah absolutely so if you think of a traditional
web app vulnerability and like a custom in a custom site it's a once-off right so you find like a sql
injection you use parameterized queries or something to to fix it and that's it done now you're off hunting
for maybe other injection points you're hunting for other kind of classifications of vulnerabilities
you use but with this kind of stuff it's it's sas right so every customer for example using salesforce
to deploy to deploy a publicly accessible site the core of it is the same across all these different
organizations so the core apis are the same how the access controls are configured are the same so if you
find a way to exploit misconfigured access controls by let's say you're unauthenticated and you can pull
data if they've accidentally made some data public you you can just use the exact same payload on another
customer so it's basically like an end it's like an end day in that regard right it's not not exactly
a zero day because these are things the customer could go in and fix uh presumably yeah and that's and
that's the kind of important distinction here is like i classify these as misconfigurations because
the customers themselves typically 99 of the time have accidentally made some data some sensitive
data public the vendor so salesforce or service now have just provided them with the tools and said
like hey we're a powerful platform you can do a lot with us use this how you want to and generally they
will say things like yeah just don't you know don't touch this or like look out for this and people
will ignore it because they want the easy button right and by pressing the easy button it's like
okay you've just leaked five million people's vaccination records you know that's that's exactly
what happens that exact scenario has happened multiple times yeah yeah yeah that's crazy dude and
and i think that's one of the beautiful things about it all as well as like you know the customer it's a
third-party software right which is so that we we know that there are patterns to it we know that there are
tricks to it um that because we can go and work with the software ourselves get our hands on it sort
of mold around with it um and then the problem that you normally have with third-party software is that
you know the company is going to kick it back and be like no that's third-party vuln you know not our
problem we're not going to pay you for that but with this one because they induced the vulnerability
themselves you know in the system then i don't know i my i would suspect that you almost always get paid
for these have you have you run into situations where they're like uh yeah but it's salesforce and
you know given some excuses like that or do they get paid like 80 90 of the time i mean so typically
when i was reporting all this stuff it's before anything is necessarily like public right so there's
a ton of pushback of like what is this what is like how did you find this like what's going on here
and there's a bit of panic and then they'll go to the vendor and the vendor will be like yeah you you
messed up your access controls here like you did this right and then they're like oh okay and they'll
pay you so since the inception of most of my research and the application of it by a lot of boat benny
hunters um globally it's become a lot more understood so i haven't heard of pushback in a long time um
um and so it's it's it's a safe safe book to hunt for right you're not going to get an na at all unless
it's at a scope of course right yeah i guess i guess uh justin it would kind of only be potentially you
know shut shut down or closed as informative if it was not like an open scope program for most bug bounty
companies where it's open scope then you know if you if they own it or it's their customers they're
probably going to pay for it yeah um the one thing that i was going to mention uh about this was
that i think uh aaron specifically and i have have farmed this uh just like one or two times on some
stuff the the biggest issues that we ran into and i know that aaron has to fight with sometimes that
app omni is that some of these vulnerabilities are in a gray area if they are defaultly configured that
way justin so you know like sass security is near impossible to configure properly for a lot of
companies because they're basically full-blown operating systems and these companies spend an
entire year instead of setting up their service now or their or their workday or their or their
salesforce but when the configuration is kind of by default exposing something then it gets kind
of tricky about whether or not it's it's on the provider's fault or if it's like on the implementer's
fault yeah yeah i could definitely see that it's up a couple times um and typically how we
would handle those responsibly is if you do find an endpoint that can be used to exfiltrate data
or leak data out of and you notice that there is a default access control that's coming with the
system out of the box you would well i would recommend to submit the access control issue to the vendor
and then for the rest of the bugs that you find that are misconfigured by the customer
those would be would be on their side of the shared responsibility model yeah and i imagine it would
be a little bit difficult too like you're gonna almost run into i don't want to break anything sort
of responses from the sas vendors where they're like oh yeah that shouldn't be the default but i don't
have any data on whether if i just globally flip this switch for everyone whether it's gonna break
anything so it's kind of hard for me to like globally be like oh maybe i should just turn this off
um so yeah i don't know i i guess that's sort of the best you know situation where it's it's default
but it's something that they can change um is that like so let's talk a little bit about your methodology
because you know looking at your blog and looking at your research you know you you've hit a bunch of
different uh sases and and identified you know misconfigurations across a lot of different sases
when you are are going into this scenario is this like your your holy grail is like this insecure
default or do you really like to try to find something that is not default um but is like the
most common configuration that the customer has to do to get the product to work yeah that's a great
question and i'll also set the the lay of the land here when we kind of use a certain nomenclature
really um so for these kinds of bugs you need two things in order to kind of retrieve this information
you need an api endpoint if you want to call it that uh to pull the data from and you need data that
is exposed okay so these api is these endpoints these the existence of these is not a vulnerability
these are used to serve a purpose and often some core functionality okay um on the flip side the access
controls those being misconfigured is on the customer and the out of the box misconfiguration is in the
vendor so i actually want to avoid situations in which the vendor has misconfigured something because
once i report a misconfigured access control they they just fix it right what i'm hoping for is
when applying these techniques to a ton of customers in an authorized fashion obviously um
they've all misconfigured access controls so it's fully on them you know that's the the dream really and
it is kind of my bread and butter it's this kind of data exposure um because there's a lot of noise
about like third-party risk and supply chain risk and a lot of the high profile
sas attacks by kind of these threat actors are through like supply chains like a compromised
service account for an integration and stuff like that we have to remember like you need a foothold there
you needed to have access to that in somewhere gained access this stuff i find so much more interesting
because you're unauthenticated like you don't need anything right so there's no prior access no prior
knowledge needed and that way it's far more dangerous and i can honestly say handle my heart
from doing this for four years now or five years actually that um i've probably compromised in an
authorized fashion through bookbending platforms and things like that like a hundred x what these threat
actors are compromising through supply chain oh yeah this is honestly the real risk with sas it's like
this unknown like what are these api endpoints like what are they used for that kind of thing um and to
speak to my methodology a little bit yeah please i never i never approach these platforms i try not to
it's hard but i i never really approach these platforms with the intent of like hacking generally
speaking i i sign up these platforms if they have some kind of free developer account or something
like that and i just try and become an expert on the platform on its functionality the use cases all of
that um so when when i was hunting or i was becoming an expert on service now that's actually how i found my
service now disclosure right where there was massively widespread misconfigurations in customer access
controls and there's api endpoints that you could pull data from so these api endpoints were not
documented anywhere they were legacy and legacy is where the gold is i know with you know all the ai
stuff um is very very hip and trendy and it introduces a lot of new attack service and i get it
but like let's not forget the stuff that's been sitting there 10 15 years yeah and it isn't even
necessarily in the forefront of the documentation or something like that deprecated but not even
disabled exactly and i'm i'm thinking probably you know you say you come in here and you kind of just
try to become an expert on it and that's what we say on the pod all the time is you know whenever
you're hacking something you just need to become the world expert on that application no matter what it is
right that's exactly um and and i think that can be accomplished a lot of times by reading the docs but
i think there's also a little bit of a hacker mentality that needs to go into it as well where
you're looking at the you know you've read the docs or whatever but then you're actually looking at the
code you're looking at the javascript files you're looking at the front end you know you're you're seeing
the way that all of these uh calls interact together and sort of reverse engineering and be like hey
what's that weird sketchy little api over there right um i think that's where we we see a lot of those bugs pop
up to yeah and aaron um maybe didn't say that specifically but that's uh often what he is
having to do at app omni he'll be he'll be given a a like a new sas vendor and be and been and be
told to like hey figure this out so we can implement it for the engineers and he basically does like that
initial recon of like okay yeah we'll use these api points to pull the users and we'll use these api
points to pull the groups and so he kind of has to become an expert in it in order to like hand that off
to our developers or to hand off to the developers at app omni so they can go through and get it all
so he's kind of like by necessity learning it as an expert which is really cool that's awesome it's
it's honestly even even further than that with with service now like i built the integration like
so i'm i'm actually a cert well i didn't renew it um last year but i'm like a certified platform
administrator and a certified developer first now how the certifications for i went to the
awesome so i actually built the the whole uh the whole integration the app um but so so what happened
there with the service now findings was like i thought to myself okay this is like a salesforce
equivalent in respect that it's very very powerful and very customizable so i thought to myself there
must be some way that they let organizations like put record data on a page okay so think about an
implementation like customer support requests surely there's a lot of use cases where someone wants to
deploy a site on service now um and allow for customers to authenticate or sign up and authenticate
and submit requests and then view their ticket information and that ticket information is being
pulled from the database right so i thought there must this functionality must exist somewhere and i
could not find it anywhere so i this and this is just a testament to how hard work outweighs
intelligence because i'm living proof okay service now um actually let you see every table in the schema okay
so just hundreds and hundreds of tables i went through every single table and was like what is this what is
this what is this for like hundreds and that's how i came across widgets um so i was looking through the
widgets and i i was using a bit of filtering because i knew the the syntax for the um the on platform
server-side programming language so i was looking for for widgets that were querying um like user input
like tables yeah that's how i came across uh simple list uh an order list which are the both of the
widgets that they're public by default um and for people watching like a widget is effectively just an api
endpoint and it would take user input uh specifically like a table name and a column name and it would let
a user read data from that table and that column if the access controls are misconfigured
so that's how i came across it so it was just through sheer countless hours and nights going
through the schema uh hunting for this stuff yeah so when you and i were hunting this and reporting it
i noticed that there were like for most implementations there was a few that were like almost always shared
which like weren't that sensitive like it was like maybe like i don't know usernames but then for
some customers we found that like the entire internal knowledge base was exposed do you like is
this d was there like what was the functionality that made them or like you know did you ever figure out
why the um certain fields or certain tables were by default enabled was it for that customer support
portal or was it for something else well all right so i think to answer your question because i remember
i think i remember the company you're talking about um and that was a knowledge-based disclosure right
and i've so i have two blogs i have one specifically for like table data and then one specifically for
um knowledge-based exposures and that's just because the access controls are implemented differently got it
um but the knowledge base um so they just misconfigured their access controls effectively what would happen
at that point was they just didn't put any access controls on because no one knew that these endpoints
existed these widgets they were like oh it's not public right um and i also remember for for that
affected organization this was actually insane their knowledge base had like access tokens in it and like
for like for like for external systems it was like yeah it was a disaster the kind of stuff that they're
storing in in knowledge base articles is is wild right like it's it was crazy um and that was actually
an interesting one because when i released the article on knowledge base disclosures which used a different
widget um service now actually stepped in and basically saved all their customers and said yeah
we're just going to lock down all of your access controls um and now they were communicating this
very very well with their customers to say like hey just letting you know this is going to happen
things might break like we'll give you some time to like you know work around it but that was
did they do this manually like do you think that they they staff members had to go in and be like
all right you know this is what the current situation is this is how the access controls should be
they just deployed it they just deployed to production everyone's stuff but they naturally
that wasn't like granular it was like blast here's access controls go yeah so they they test all this
stuff beforehand naturally um and and because they were trying to gauge the best way of solving this
problem other than because they were sending communications out to customers and saying like
hey your access controls suck like everything's exposed but the issue with that is not everyone
reads their emails so some stuff was still exposed stuff was just exposed everywhere um so they kind of
took that brave leap and i have to give them kudos for that because they put their customers in a much
better position it's a difficult position they've now got to uh some organizations may need to figure
out a way around it to implement whatever functionality they they have there but um they're better off for
it and look i'm sure some of them have just undone it they just yeah just flip it back because if they
were using it for like an external dev documentation or developer portal or something then where there was
nothing sensitive in it it was totally fine to be that way they could have just rolled that back the other
thing i was going to ask you about the one of the i think it's the simple list widget is the um i
noticed that when you and i reported it there was some specific um there was like one specific endpoint
we were using but then i was like talking like your blog got posted and i remember seeing a bunch of
people like tweeting or talking about it afterwards where they were using a completely different type of
payload it was like we were using like a post request or something and they were using like a get
request at a different endpoint do you remember the nuances around that or like um you know does that ring any
bells there were there were like a there were like five or six maybe a lot more um different widgets
that you could use um so i mean that's that's really where it comes from um there was some
limitations with some uh some widgets would allow you to kind of filter through the data which could
be helpful when looking for particularly sensitive things like phone numbers or whatever it is um but
all of those got hit with the the patch so they did roll out a kind of a defense in depth mechanism
like a security guard rail for those those widgets uh in which they effectively made it so organizations
would need to like set all these system properties in order to allow for data to be exposed to them
um i know because i i i finally talking about this i know you guys were curious like is there any more
widgets like can we get more widgets um not that i know of unfortunately uh the knowledge base one
i believe still works so there's like a ton of knowledge based ones they all still work um there's
no i don't believe there's any like prerequisites such as a system property or anything that needs to be
set by the customer um so those are still applicable sweet yeah i've got two more quick things about
service now before we pivot to something else the first thing is one thing that i saw that i'm sure
you've seen a few times justin which is really cool i know we have a lot of program managers listening
is um for sas uh specific things if you're worried about them being misconfigured and you want to give
researchers a specific target to hunt for you can actually put a flag like you can create a user where
their details are a flag and then if someone's able to get access to that they can submit it for a
vulnerability or in service now it can be a ticket or it can be a a user the user details like user pii
or something and like a sign or put a flag there i know that t-mobile has done that and it's a pretty
cool way to like have someone validate that they got access to something they shouldn't have inside one
of these sas platforms but what i was going to ask you aaron specifically was one if you have any
comments on that of course you can mention it but do you think they're like what would be if there's
any hackers out there that have been looking at service now because i'm pretty sure they have a
private program floating around or at least a public vdp what what are some areas for future research
on service now that uh maybe has been interesting to you if there's a specific api path or piece of
functionality or feature that recently came out that you would recommend if the hacker is looking for
something to dig into what should they dig into that's a great question that's a fantastic question
um what did you not have time to get back to i guess is the real question i know you've got notes over
there probably not well um i have looked at a ton of stuff um i would say things like like ux data
brokers um so that's another kind of like api endpoint uh data brokers i'd recommend playing around
with the ui builder and so you're designing like a front end and you've got a couple of different um
means to which you can implement the back end functionality so looking through those available
api endpoints that can also return data uh playing around with those and see if there's kind of another
maybe not like a simple list but if there's any kind of um maybe lack of validation on a param or
see if you can get around it yeah that's that's definitely what i recommend but still kind of legacy
stuff um i know they are doing a lot with with ai as well so naturally i mean that's kind of your your
wheelhouse um but yeah i think i when it comes to data exposure i've rinsed service now fairly hard
look elsewhere leave it alone yeah yeah that's funny man it's that you know one on one note actually
when you talk about what i recommend for for hackers and sass apps and things like that um
i would definitely recommend that this will require some money some some prior input if you've got a group
of skilled people because a lot of these these sass apps cost a lot of money like a lot we're talking
i think i've seen like 20 km a month in like at a peak oh my god band together with a group of guys
group of bug bounty hunters get yourself like a production license for some big sass organization um
um i'm not going to say which ones but ones that are old uh and ensure that you know that the you're
getting the right license you know something that allows you to implement that kind of external
functionality and i've no doubt as well like five or six people or up to eight people just hacking on
the one platform like you'll make your money back definitely but it is that is kind of the the barrier
uh or the entry barrier for people getting into this it's like the instances cost a lot of money
i do have to go through a bit of a process sometimes to buy them it's it's a little bit it's crazy too
because you say wow you know 20 grand uh yeah up to 20 grand a month and i'm like oh my gosh that's
crazy and then you think about like wow we pop one critical you know on like one of these major
organizations and that could be 20 grand easy you know um it's i think that the investment is definitely
there yeah yeah it's funny we've had that in in app omni where i i've made the argument i was like
look we need this license like i'm telling you there's stuff here we need this i'm gonna tell
like okay for one month you've got one month so for one month i just sweat it out i'm like come on
return on investment please um yeah so before before justin takes us to the uh to talking about
salesforce or one of these other topics we've got listed here i did want to reframe one thing you
said you know i think you said you have basically rent service now for all they're worth but just
like as a reframe to you personally and to the audience i think it's like a really healthy reminder
to be like no what you actually did is help secure hundreds or thousands of companies and and and
hundreds of millions of users data and so uh i'm thankful to to your work in that regard and i think
that list listeners and customers should be too so yeah absolutely yeah big shout out to service now as
well because they handled it very very well given the circumstances um so kudos because to them too
okay so i'm dealing with two you know app omni guys here so i i gotta just take a step back in and sort
of um recap for the for the sas for the newbie sas hacker like myself you know what what exactly the
approach is here so for service now what you guys are saying is we need to utilize these specific
sections uh relating to widgets which i imagine is you know loading widgets onto a page you know on the
front end or whatever the api is associated with that um to leak data about the given objects inside
inside service now is that that's sort of like the tldr of this approach tldr widgets api endpoints
provide a table name provide column names or whatever kind of input to leak the data and if
there's misconfigured access controls then the data will be shown yeah and if listeners are confused like
aaron's two blogs on service now are extremely clear it's like it walks you through exactly what they
all mean and exactly the request to use so yeah yeah and so the the widget piece there the reason
why using a widget here is important is because that's that piece that you mentioned before where
it's like that's the api endpoints that we use to pull to pull that data out and there could be other
api endpoints as well they can give us access to that that misconfigured data so so the the overall
problem here is that there's bad access controls you know on the data itself but then we are using
the widget related api endpoints to extract and and to get at that data that is actually has bad
access controls is that right completely correct yeah okay and so then what you were saying before
i was like okay now we got to find another avenue maybe it's not simple widget like it was before a
simple list widget um but maybe you know it's in the the ux uh what was that piece could you say it
one more time the ux designer or something because yeah the data brokers yeah yeah yeah there's a ton
of legacy widget like um apis out there so look for those hidden gems and maybe you'll find something
that you could use to hack thousands data brokers okay and that's a part of the like ux builder stuff
that's related to service now and then what we'd be looking for is another one of those sort of um api
endpoints where we could query the data that is already misconfigured because of access control
stuff right and and and i think i think the interesting thing here is that the fix you know
you said was and and correct me if i'm wrong here not necessarily to fix it at the widget level which is
that api endpoint um but but to fix the overall access control problem that that happens with with
service now so service now pushed a bunch of access control updates to their users so so now even if
we find another api endpoint where we can query misconfigured data i mean are do you expect to see as
grossly misconfigured access controls as we did see the first time or do you think that those access
controls have been shered up in large part oh yeah you'll still see so many so many 100 there's going
to be a ton of regressions absolutely um and i want to touch on that point of yes service now pushed out
some by default access control changes and yes at the widget in the widget code they implemented some
guardrails where it's like the organization has to flip a flag for the widget to be accessible
but too many organizations are gonna fix it on that latter part they'll be like well i can just undo these
access control changes now because the widget isn't accessible um that's what's gonna happen right okay
gotcha so there's two fixes share up the access controls and then fix your widget and a lot of
people will be like ah okay widgets not accessible no worries and then leave access controls wide open
and that's why we go search for another api endpoint another path through data brokers or whatever where we
can get at this misconfigured data yeah and i also think like they're going to be adding uh new features as
well justin and a lot of sas providers have this is like a thing aaron always looks for because he
kind of coached me and helped me on this as well when doing sas security research is like basically
guest user access and so that's kind of like the you know keyword that kind of makes a lot of this
possible is there's just um and guest user is almost like one step away from unauth in fact you know
most people could still probably just consider it unauth but if you think about it in the context of the
application it still is giving you some sort of token it's giving you some sort of cookie or it's giving you
some sort of api token that is expected to have like little to no sensitive data access but often
it does get misconfigured to have it and i would say one step further than that justin like let's say
service now fixed all unauth and all guest user stuff like there's going to be some organizations
where like you can get like as a customer you can get like a support access and now support access might
be able to have access to like all all cross customers right they're like so each of these api
endpoints each of these widgets each of these pieces of functionality could be vulnerable at any
step they might be on aught they might be accessed with like a no privilege token and then they might
be they might be misconfigured with a privilege token so those are kind of the ways that i think about it
gotcha aaron any comments on that and how like the different roles are utilized by the different
organizations i'll touch on that more when we talk about the salesforce things um i'll have
a few time for for power platform too i'll be talking about that a lot okay sweet yeah let's hop right
into it then salesforce um and and i sort of read over the whole salesforce thing and man it's it's
it makes me want to go hack on this stuff man it's it's crazy the way that they've got this whole thing
configured um and i guess the first question that i wanted to say here was this article was written
this legendary article this is like like whenever anybody talks about salesforce they're like oh they're
using salesforce i'm like uh uh this blog go you know like i always just like copy paste this blog and
be like hack it with this um and so very legendary blog on the space um and and it was but it was
written in 2020 so five years ago um and i'm wondering if uh all of this stuff i kind of know
the answer to this already but i'm wondering you know uh how much of this is still applicable and uh
it you know has much changed since the 2020 write-up of of this very applicable very very applicable
exact same payload i found this i found this on a program like two weeks ago so oh my gosh
there yeah there has been some minor minor changes um with respect to some of the payloads
where they've actually baked in some restrictions uh and people won't really know this stuff unless
they're very salesforce savvy um so what those restrictions are or one example restriction was
so using one of those um payloads from the article at that time you were able to access
both record data so data being certain tables and also data being stored in what are called custom
settings now typically custom settings are very sensitive so what salesforce did there they made it
so that that paid those payloads couldn't be used to access custom settings um so there's like
minor kind of baked in restrictions like that but um yeah i mean joseph and someone two weeks ago so
it's still very very applicable and at up omni we have so many sales for salesforce customers and
prospective customers that we still see this stuff right like it's it's wild yeah absolutely and so
there's lots of different pieces to salesforce security there's like the um apex classes there's the
salesforce object query language um and all that stuff what would you say is like the 80 20 the the
things that we are going to get the most you know bang for our buck for with like knowing about those
salesforce misconfigurations and security controls all right i'll talk about three things there well it's
really two things and then one is just like a tip so the first is the access control misconfigurations in
the same manner that we spoke about with respect to service now so using the payloads um that are
outlined in in my blog looking for objects that are publicly accessible that you can read sensitive
data from okay um so there's payloads in there that you enumerate all the object names and then you can
just iterate the extraction payload effectively over those object names that's that's one two is the apex
so the custom apex uh code uh so briefly what that is i spoke about it in the initial um kind of book
book talk apex is like server-side code it's sales forces kind of proprietary language right and some
uh object-oriented language apex provides the business logic so if someone clicks a button on a
form it could fire off some apex that would maybe retrieve some data or insert some data um so it's
that kind of server-side logic so is that written by the customer so yes it is written by the customer okay
no there is some other box click a button and and then it does like an rpc call is like a remote
procedure call type thing on and on the server or right so okay we're getting into it okay so effectively
um these so in salesforce you can have what are known as digital um experiences previously they're
called lightning communities so it's just like a website deployed in salesforce okay and how it was built
uh a while ago was through what i call aura components and these are just front-end components
like forms and buttons and you would pair an aura component like a form or login form or something
with an apex class that was or what we call aura enabled so when apex is aura enabled it means it is
accessible via the aura api okay and that's what we can get access to it through so if you look at the
payloads in my in my article you'll notice that those payloads are being sent to the aura api
because that's the api endpoint that exists within these public sites to put on salesforce so yeah it's
the aura kind of ui framework being paired with the kind of back-end apex um business logic and where
these kind of issues arise and why this is kind of like the 80 20 is you've got a lot of customers
implementing their own functionality so when i spoke about that bug for some reason they were
integrating with an external storage bucket through apex so really what was probably probably happening
there was using um the aura api that kind of apex was being called and then in the in the core code uh
the core apex code in the salesforce platform on the server side that apex was probably pulling some
credentials from uh credential store like name credentials or something in salesforce and then
pushing that to the um the storage bucket so i have a specific paper on apex i don't know how applicable it
is today with because i talk about how you can like find what parameters are required you can find apex
methods that aren't even like in use yeah so definitely give that a look to understand the
fundamentals but it's like think of it as just like aura enabled apex are just custom api endpoints
that's right that's all it is and and you say there's there's a way to enumerate those from the
external attack surface without like having to read like the javascript files or whatever client side
code we have in place you you you would need to to kind of pull apart the the client side a little bit
okay so there is some i think that i mean i'd hope this quite by now there's some automated tool to do
this for you but uh you might have to do it manually um so you're effectively pulling apart um yeah as you
said like the javascript and looking for the methods um that are exposed to the or api and you know what
what inputs are they expecting okay this parameter and it's a string and you play around with those and
so the reason i i mentioned that this is so important is take a scenario in which you're applying method
one of querying for exposed objects right and let's say all the access controls are locked down okay so
you're out of luck nothing you can do well you can develop apex in an insecure way so you can develop
apex in a way that it just doesn't respect access controls i've seen that running as like a system
user or something on the back end so yeah it's called um like without sharing is when it's running
in system context when it's running in that context it effectively means that whatever it's accessing
it's it's not respecting whose data you can read so you could i've seen apex that just pulls all users
so straight away okay you've got phone numbers everything addresses or whatever it is there's a
lot of different things that you can do there is what you alluded to earlier the socle um query language
which is like sql um very very similar it just doesn't allow for any dml so like no insert update
delete just just read only so you can have instances where user input is being put into a
um socle query but it's not being sanitized so it opens up these kind of very sql injection like attacks
um so i speak about that i believe in the in the apex white paper as well uh and and that's why it's
important because what might be restricted by access controls may not be restricted by this this kind of
custom apex that's being developed and exposed as an api aaron you should tell justin the way that
i don't remember if it was you or if so we actually figured it out and then he told us and you used
it or something later but um i assume that it was probably your finding how did you uh what was the
workaround you found for leaking named i think it's fixed at this point but there was a way to get
around leaking name credentials yeah yeah justin i love this dude this sounds great yeah so um yeah it's
okay this is an interesting one so the name credentials in salesforce i very briefly mentioned it um it's
a method in which salesforce can integrate with an external platform so you as a salesforce
administrator you log into salesforce and go to the name credential page and you can basically specify uh
again typically an api endpoint and you can specify how it uh authenticates so you can provide like an
access token you can provide like so this is just straight up credentials like these are like secrets
basically right you can provide credentials to it and um once you save that you can call it from apex
so it's just a way that allows developers to call an external system in an authenticated manner
without needing to embed the credentials in the code in the apex code yeah exactly right so it's just safer
um now there's two ways you can set them credentials up so one is or was in the past called named
principle named principle means that anyone who's accessing um or performing this call out to an
external system through apex everyone's using the same type of credentials it's the credentials that
were provided when it was created and then there's also per user which means that each individual
user has their own okay um now we all know that no one's using the ladder okay everyone's using the
shared credential that's why this happened um and so the issue with time like hacking this stuff is
you can't just run apex right unauthenticated like you can't just run server side code like that would be
insane right um but if you were to go to a site to put in salesforce that allowed you to sign up
you're then what's called generally a community site user and you've got extra privileges just by signing up
you're going to sign up and you're going to sign up and you're going to sign up and you're going to
sign up and you're going to sign up and you're going to sign up and you're going to sign up and
do the normal like sign up to create a support user or whatever it's like and like submit my ticket
or whatever and now that i've got this community user i can just run apex code within the within
the the privileges of my specific user as an anonymous user oh wow okay well you're not
anonymous you're like authenticated you're just like a low priv user you're an external user um but the issue
was like okay yes this execute anonymous apex it does run with like it doesn't run in system context so
it's only in your privileges with name credentials if it was set up as a named principle aka the
credentials are the you the credentials used are shared by everyone you could just brute force the
the name credential so now and all you need to do that is basically um you would so when you perform
a call out through apex to the name with the name credential it's just a label so you could say like
amazon okay and in the apex you'd say call it um call on amazon so you would just brute force all the
commonly used names so you could go to github scrape a ton of name credential names
turn them into a word list and through that mechanism you could see the responses from these
apis and you're authenticated because you're using the credentials that were set up by the admin and
they're all shared under the name principle um and the best part as well is you can modify the path so
you can actually like access resources that like outside of what was intended so yeah it was a really
interesting one um that was once again another one of those things where because i had that on
platform knowledge i knew there was an execute anonymous api i knew that you needed to be somewhat
authenticated to use it dude that's that's gonna be a new term some somewhat authenticated like i i so
many bugs happen in the somewhat authenticated uh you know environment that's that's really key and and so
that's the third thing i was going to talk about when i just asked my question so the first was
kind of that misconfigured access skills for objects the second was um custom apex a custom apex
exposes as an or api and the third is just privilege escalation yourself by signing up okay you would
have you have no idea how many lightning communities i've tested that were so locked down when you're
authenticated you sign up two seconds later you click an email confirmation link in your inbox
you're now authenticated as a community site user and all of a sudden everything's accessible everything's
just everything's accessible you'll also then have access to not only more objects chances are you'll be
able to see um some some leaked data that you couldn't see before we'll also have more custom apex so
you're just expanding on it uh is it so cool or apex it sometimes will return like uh an obfuscated
response for secrets and then there you there you thought there was a way around it by like renaming
it as a part of the query or renaming the the key as a part of the there's a lot of stuff i can't talk
about it um okay we're gonna have to sleep that who knows um yeah there's there's a lot of of
interesting attack vectors so yeah i would advise everyone to uh just read the original paper read
the or the original enumerated blog read the apex white paper on abomni um and look into kind of uh
socle as well see how that underlying those online database calls are working with apex and yeah it's
very very fruitful maybe wow maybe one of clarification here aaron because i know that people have
messaged me about this in the past socle injection is not always sensitive correct so if just because
you found a socko injection it doesn't mean necessarily that there's going to be sensitive
data accessible to the authentication context that you're in right gotta validate these things 100
right it's you can't just throw well this wouldn't work for soccer anyway but you know with like
sql injection people just like throw in a dash or like a percent of 27 um it's like oh it threw an
error so like it's probably tons of sensitive stuff and you find out like the db is just empty it's
like unused so same thing here make sure you validate what is accessible and what is not
accessible like it's it's crucial because the last thing you want to do is go through all the effort
of writing a report to be hit with an na and like i think like a 10 is it still in the minus 10
reputation fine yeah yeah so it's brutal so don't be lucky so what is your go-to payload to like let's
say you had socko injection what is your go-to at least like thing to try to achieve with socko injection
uh sense of information disclosure right because we're we are limited with respect to the operations
we can perform it's only read and you are also limited to the context of the query so what object
is being accessed what's being pulled and how is it being pulled so the same way if you look at sql injection
your injection point can be in different clauses so it could be like the where clause right
same with socko injection depending on for example if you have a apex is promoting a socko query
and your user input is being part of like uh it's being used in the like operator okay you you you might
be able to get some good sensitive information um through like using like wild cards right to just pull
everything or yeah is wild card in socko the percent symbol i believe so i believe so um could be okay
okay solid so so there's three let me i'm just going to repeat it back there's three primary things
there we're hitting these objects which is kind of like tables right if i understand correctly yeah so
you know trying to see if there are any tables that we have access to that we shouldn't be able to have
access to right through through the uh through the aura api um same thing we're hitting apex classes
where it's like okay let's see if we can enumerate all the apex classes either via you know looking at
the client side or like that's exactly the client side we just look through the client side identify
what apex classes we have access to what kind of server-side functionality we can trigger and what
kind of permissions that might access and then third is like sign up for a community user and become a
community user and then you'll get access to that that sort of um ability to execute some apex code
yourself um and then you can also get access to maybe different objects and stuff like that because
you're a different role is that is that when when you sign up as uh i'm becoming a community user so
um i wouldn't focus too much on like being able to execute apex yourself i would look towards okay what
objects do you have access to and what additional custom apex do i have access to um it's interesting
because i i would think that if you if it exposed like a you know interface for you to run some some
code then i feel like you should be able to utilize that to check the objects that you have access to
is that is that not accurate so you can it's just slower oh really okay yeah because if you use my payload
um for everyone that uses burp suite um shout out for that um you put in your payload into like intruder
and then you put your characters just around the the object name and you just throw in the word list
and let it run and you just put the apex you kind of have to write like the sockle query and then you've
got to like basically dump it into the response and it's like an ugly response because you're technically
like putting into like a debug statement okay yeah it's not it's not you could it's just not as efficient
okay okay solid so then you we just brute force for the for the specific object names and you've got
the payloads in here um in the in the article that will allow us to just hit those specific objects
um and then we kind of iterate through and check the permissions that we have as a community user and
maybe compare those to the ones that we had as an anonymous user and say okay you know here's the
difference maybe i should sort of zoom in on that one a little bit yeah absolutely and you can you can
even possibly chain the two you could get a list of objects as a community user that you couldn't see
before and maybe as a guest user an authenticated user there was apex that lets you put in an object name
so then you can pass it back and now you've just elevated the criticality and you found another bug
so try and play around with it and kind of be smart about it too that's a great idea so use try to
utilize the information that you get as a community user saying oh i've got access to this object i've
got access to this object uh and then take that back to unauthenticated apex i like that that's that's
really good all right so just looking through here um here i'm gonna go ahead and share my screen
for those of you that are on on youtube um i'm i'm just scrolling through aaron's article here on
salesforce and we're looking at the payload glossary section um can you just sort of talk me through
these payloads that you have um on here and give some some context surrounding this yeah and funnily
enough the first two it's all you want it's all you need um this is the object related stuff yeah the
rest is just like you look better than i am at this stuff so the first two um okay so the first one
is the payload that we use to actually extract the data from objects so you'll see it's kind of a
messy payload but this is just the format of the aura api um like post data um you'll see in the
entity name or id you'll see marker right and that's where you put the object name okay it'll
automatically pull those those records for you okay well how do we get the object name that's payload
number two so payload number two can be run as is um it's been a long time since i've run it so i'm
not going to i'm not too sure what the output's still going to be but that would return you a list
of uh of objects so you would run the second pillow at first you would copy all the lists of objects in
the response so you've got your out of the box objects that salesforce provides you like the user
object and you may also see some custom objects that the customers created themselves and you'll
take that you'll copy it into intruder and you'll use the first payload to uh iterate over them to
see if there's any data exposed through an access control misconfiguration okay and then usually from
there justin i'll sort by a largest response size and that's what you know those are the tables that
typically exist yeah right that makes sense and and and then you know we're just kind of looking
through to see what kind of data is returned back see if we're dumping data about other users or not
okay cool that makes sense so get get the use the second payload to get all of the currently available
objects and then use the first payload to get um the data out of those specific objects and and kind
of see how many how many different items we have or what kind of information we have access to now these
this payload that you're here you know you put in here it like you said it is a little bit messy
and there's like this descriptor component and then there's like um the params the aspect uh which i i
assume is specific to the actual function we're calling um can you talk a little bit about that
structure uh for the for the listeners yeah yeah and you got to remember that like this is so this
specific payload well all of the ones you're seeing in this article are salesforce created so their vendor
created apex okay so these are apex this is going to be similar for all the apex classes somewhat yeah
to a degree um so certain things will be different so at the moment on on the screen like all of that
stuff um so the id will always be a present parameter right and that does not matter the value of
that it doesn't matter at all okay if you look at the descriptor okay so that is the actual apex being
called so it's like the path to the apex code exactly exactly so get items there at the very end
so it's the suffix so that's your apex method okay and selectable list data provided controller is your
class that's right okay class then method right exactly um so if you've got custom apex naturally
that'll be a different string than than what's apparent there um calling descriptor does not matter
and then you've got the prom so the prams um the promise parameter will always be present okay um
um and naturally the parameters within that and the values will depend on how that apex works so
these parameters you're seeing such as layout type and entity name or id will not apply necessarily to
other ones if you look at the second payload it's got different parameters um so when we speak about
like or when you talk about custom apex um the importance of kind of manually pulling apart the
javascript to to look for those parameter signatures is because of this like we want to
craft a payload that's valid so that javascript will contain what needs to go in that params list
and what kind of value is expecting like a boolean or or a string okay so so it's all about
so in salesforce it's all about identifying these apex classes and or using these apex classes right
the default ones from salesforce to query specific objects and to try to attack uh custom apex classes
that the the customer has has written and in order to do that we need to know the descriptor right and
the descriptor contains the uh sort of a path to the class that is uh the apex class and then a specific
method descriptor as well um and then once we've got that we need to identify the specific parameters
that we pass into that and then boom we're off to the races we're calling that apex function just like
sort of like we would be in a normal rest api like you need to identify the path to the rest api and then
the parameters that it takes for it to actually function um and and that's this is just the salesforce
version of that yeah exactly and so that that's why this article pairs really really nicely with the um
the app on the white paper on apex because they complement you to each other so the white paper
will explain a lot of the format and the reasons as to why the payloads are as they are gotcha i'm
gonna i'm gonna grab that uh paper and put it in the notes hold on i put it in the notes already justin
um oh perfect yeah um i will say to the listener so if you're interested in like digging into this or
looking for it specifically one kind of key thing to note is uh what to search for so if you have like
some massive burp or kaido projects and you're wanting to search through them you want to search
for slash aura a u r a it's a word that uh aaron says kind of funnily since he's from ireland
um i'm just kidding it's actually a hard one to say even closer i live closer to where the language
was invented that's fair that's fair that's fair no and or you can search for uh slash s slash or slash sf
sites for salesforce sites um those are kind of things you can search for and um and then with those
requests you can kind of read his blog and kind of start to build out the actual request sweet sweet
solid okay all right so that that covers service now in salesforce any any last little shout outs or
tidbits of wisdom you can give us aaron on the on the salesforce front i think that's everything on
the salesforce front to be honest with you um it doesn't need to be too complex like these are tried
and tested methods that i've been using for four years right now i've really changed too much so um yeah
you learn learn those um those aspects of of testing salesforce um communities you've you've
put yourself in a good spot awesome okay cool um and then the next one we had on the list here was one
that came out a little bit more recently through app omni which is the microsoft power pages stuff
um can you kind of hit us with that research and and tell us a bit about it yeah absolutely and
and this one's kind of interesting in contrast to how i found the service on the salesforce stuff
because microsoft are very very open about like every api path so i didn't need to spend a ton of
time on the platform to discover um the api through which data is exposed um so getting into that the power
platform is a microsoft um of sas offering and it's like low code web development you know so
very very similar to like your ui builder for uh in service now and things like that
what it allows you to do is drag and drop create a website um that also can store data and fetch data
from microsoft dataverse which is like the database and so it's really um attractive because you don't
really need any prior like programming knowledge there's no like apex equivalent there or like um
proprietary language associated with it uh i had noticed when going through the microsoft
documentation for power platform and it's more specifically power pages is what it's called yeah
um with power pages they mentioned odata feeds and there had been some research done on our data feeds
in the past as a means to kind of exfiltrate data that's been exposed through misconfigured access
controls again but i noticed this banner and i said like oh we've just deprecated this you should use
this other api instead so i just i started reading that and it was just as simple as like slash underscore
api slash table name yeah dude i had that in the notes i was like is is i love how like we just spent
so long on like service now and salesforce like and then you got to hit the aura and the aura lets you
access the apex and the classes and then when we get to power pages you're like yeah so there's this
underscore api path and then you hit that with the name of the column and it just dumps like what is
going on here man it's funny because like slash api with no underscore is the authenticated one
underscore as a prefix is that's the secret path oh my god so yeah same kind of stuff again tons of
power pages customers were just exposing their data through uh misconfigured access controls so what
they would do is they would give the anonymous user access to way too much information um which is
funny because on power platform it's kind of tricky to expose so much data like it's it's i i'm actually
surprised you have to jump through like a couple hoops you've got to make the table accessible to
that api then you've got to pick which columns you want to make accessible um for that table then you've
got to pick which role and then you've got to pick so like the anonymous role then you've got to pick like
okay what who whose records should they be able to see so there's like four steps there so i really don't
know what's been going on with people but wow yeah a ton tons of customers were misconfiguring it and
it was an easy button scenario again so you could let's say a customer wanted to expose like the
first names of some users for some public blog where people can comment or something sure what they would
do is that if they expose the um the account object or something they would intend to let's say expose like
five fields like the first name maybe the last name a couple things time zone um but they didn't
want to type in all the five fields so instead they were like oh i'll just use the wild card i'll expose
like every field and that's how it happens and then they assign it to the anonymous role and uh all of
a sudden every column like their address or or their phone number um would be would be exposed
and uh yeah that's pretty much that but the same tip applies for this as i gave for salesforce which is
you'll see in my blog i talk about the different error messages you will receive from the api endpoint
when you're attempting to access objects so you'll receive uh certain error messages that are obvious
indications that it's not accessible so you try and access an object it'll say like insufficient
permissions or like uh even better it'll say the object's not exposed so if it says the object's not
exposed to the api you're done okay you're cooked if it says something like oh the wild card is not
supported it means that you actually have to add a fields parameter and manually brute force or
programmatically even script which fields are exposed so that's a good error to get because you know you
might be able to get something and then another one is oh you don't have sufficient permissions
which is also sometimes a nice one to get because you just self-escalate by registering once again
that netted me most of my findings so i spoke about in the nhs so um from in the uk it's like um
the government healthcare body and they exposed like um over a million um records uh individuals records
um and that was through power pages through power pages okay because i remember you reported something
similar through salesforce like a few years ago around covet time right that was actually
organization government's health care oh that was ireland's high health care yeah i did finish with
ireland i was done there i went to the uk closest island and i was like right you're next
uh yeah that was one of the situations where i was able to just watch out scotland yeah right seriously
yeah yeah i'm i'm not gonna say too much about that but um yeah it's it's very interesting and i also
one of the weird things about power pages is the amount of public sector government bodies using it
i imagine so just tons which was really strange because i thought it more of like a hobbyist
developer kind of like you want to host a blog but uh no there's tons of government applications
across like healthcare or like your local council you're signing up for like a permit or something
yeah it's something about that pseudo tech man like sharepoint and like these sort of things
business people love it man they're all naturally gonna be microsoft customers for a long time and
they probably just want to stick to the uh what they know and it does integrate with other kind
of microsoft products within the power platform suite so it does make sense um it was just something
interesting that i noted how widely have you hunted this um not that widely i'll be honest with you i was
gonna say i'm on a program where i'm looking at a power page right now so i may have you try to stay
on after the pod to take a quick look one thing that i did notice was their table or i guess yeah
their object names are all custom so their prefix would like the name of the app underscore then
the thing so like it's not like accounts or contacts it's like something something something
underscore account something something something underscore contacts yeah the annoying thing about
power pages um for recall correctly was like you can't there's no payload like in salesforce that
just give you all the custom because all the objects that we found yes unless those objects
yes exactly unless those objects are actually being used or embedded in the client side um maybe something
deprecated api call it isn't actually being made it's hard to discover them but uh yeah i didn't hunt
that wildly for it honestly i didn't hunt that wildly for anything other than salesforce i think
salesforce that broke my spirit a little bit because no honestly it did that's hilarious i
found it i was reporting it and i spent like two days of my life with barely any sleep just reporting
it and i got so sick of writing reports um so i actually started paying my non-technical friends
to like write reports i was like my dude please just write this um yeah yeah and then shortly after that
i just made it public i was like i can't do this anymore like wow it was just writing reports
it's getting so tedious because there wasn't the guy we want man he's like i can't write all these
reports might as well just give it to the community yeah there was no no chat gbt i mean if back if
there was i mean yeah i would have rinsed it completely but um no i wasn't i wasn't doing that
i went for uh cheap labor for my friends and then publicly disclosing it um so so looking through all
of this i mean the the big takeaways from from this one for me are look for powerappsportals.com
right anywhere where that might be being used and that's the sort of suffix for anything running on on
power uh power apps here and and then once we're there we hit that underscore api endpoint and we try
to identify what objects we can hit and and kick back and then based off of the given um error messages
that will come back from that api like uh resource not found or attribute attribute star in table
contact is not enabled for the web api or something like that um you know going through each one of
these errors that's listed here in the um write-up we determine okay this we have access to this object
but we don't have access to like this field at the field level security and then we identify
what kind of things we can access and then we dump it all yeah yeah and the important thing to note
there is like you so what you can't enumerate all of the custom table names right um and you can't
even really technically enumerate the out of the box tables what i did personally like anyone can do this
is if you sign up for free you just get a trial of um power pages uh sign up you can get access to
the entire schema the entire like out of the box schema you can export it and just get yourself a nice
word list of all of the default object names uh you could then also go to github or ask chat gpt what
the most common custom object names are throw those into um because yeah you can't you can't just send
a payload like salesforce to enumerate them and the other thing i want to mention that you touched on was
you know how do we identify these power pages sites so we talk about like the powerappsportals.com
domain i think there is also off the top of my head i think it's microsoft crmportals.com
okay that's another one like um like a legacy um legacy domain i think it's used any longer but
for for new tenants but a lot of customers are still on it and you will also see and this is all in
the microsoft documentation online for power pages there are custom domains for us government too
okay they will have their own um probably because of like a fed ramp stock or something
right they need to comply with for regulations very cool okay so we've got we've got microsoft crm
portals and power apps portals and then potentially some other custom stuff there is on my head but
all on the um microsoft documentation online okay we'll see if we can identify it drop it in the notes
afterwards um wow dude okay and then let me ask you this so sign up for this how do i get into the
somewhat authenticated state is there ever like um and i guess this could apply to the other um sas
providers as well is there ever a scenario where there is you know not a clear signup flow for the
somewhat authenticated state but you know the api endpoint so you can hit it and be like and register
yourself an account i have that i have that exact problem right now there's no way to sign up in
the app but i want to be able to sign up is that possible are you just hacking right now maybe
yeah so just apply all the methodology um so yeah what what can happen is i have seen this happen
is instead of actually disabling registrations organizations will just deactivate the signup page or
this is actually even worse this is i've seen this even more prevalently is they'll just not list
the signup page in the menu on the site right you can just like force browsing you can just navigate
to the signup page um if it's just not listed but not deactivated as well do you know do you know what
the path is or no for for what joseph what are you hacking right now for the for the login page on
powerapps um i i i can uh i'll sync up with you offline i'll read that one i can take a look but
um yeah you can you can use like force browsing to kind of go to these um signup pages if they
haven't been fully deactivated uh that's definitely one way to do it and um if people want to identify
what those endpoints are once again for like um salesforce uh like power pages get a trial
just keep going down yeah deploy a under free trials as well deploy a website on power page or
salesforce and look at the um url when you navigate to like the templated signup page so they'll have
like a skeleton template that you can just deploy for like a blog or something and yeah just copy the
url that sends to and see if that's uh you know exposed and not deactivated for these for these
other sites yeah so i will say there are other paths that are pre-pended with underscore since
i've been looking at one i'll mention it for the listener there's like an underscore services slash
and then like custom like uh services that can be ran on the on the back end and i think that's more
than just data it's actually running some sort of code on the back end they can set up like a custom
service inside of power apps and then there's slash underscore layout i think where you can put like
a custom html that you can load in the page so uh so there's slash underscore api slash underscore
services and slash underscore layout um that are all used on power apps pages very cool all right man now
now i kind of got the the blood flow and now i want to go hack this thing with uh with joseph um i did
have one more question aaron um what are some other big sas companies you kind of got your eyes on
for some more uh security research that that who who should we go pop and find those configurations on
i mean yeah i mean i've got ones that like i i haven't disclosed and publish everything
yeah um there's stuff in the pipeline there's stuff in the pipeline um i'll give you some some names
because i simply don't want to do it myself god like all like i don't like the uis and just
i'm just not bothered anymore i'm running out of steam here guys so yeah um i would look at
organizations like sap okay geez i wonder why that's the one you chose i mean yes i'm not gonna
say the exact reasons but i think we're all thinking it yeah yeah because with you have to remember like
with sap or like um these kind of erp vendors not just sap other erp vendors i'm alluding to um they've
typically got like a suite of products so salesforce has like a suite of products you've got the core
salesforce platform which we talked about but they also have like marketing cloud which is like a
separate product um so sap they've got a ton um adobe have got a ton i think we all know adobe am
probably most of your every buck hundred knows that yeah yeah yeah right so that's what we're
hoping for we're hoping for like a second one of those right um yeah look at look at getting um
getting access to those tenants unfortunately it'll be a slow process because acquiring access is one
that set you back a little bit of money so group together okay everyone put it in a little bit makes
it much much more affordable uh two yeah the process is kind of lengthy like uh you will have
it's not just oh enter your credit card and you know pay now you probably have to email someone and
then it'll get back to you with a quote and then but i promise you i promise you it'll be worth it in
the end because if you manage to get like an sap tenant you're probably the only group of hackers with an
sap tenant ever right so you're gonna find not just misconfig you'll probably find zero days you'll
find a ton of stuff and if you work at it i promise you you'll make your money back like just no question
yeah yeah 100 i personally would love to see because i never figured it out i had i obviously worked at
app omni and one of the things that i looked deeply into was workday um they may or may not have a private
program floating around there out there but um one thing that i think would be some amazing research
let me it's like the biggest hr platform by far and they do have a way for you to be
kind of authenticated or sort of authenticated whatever we called it um basically uh there are
portals where like you can sign up and apply for jobs there's like workday like job portals and so
you can like sign up on there and you're given at least some sort some form of auth token and so i
think with that it'd be really interesting if you could then pivot into or see any data that was
actually or get access to any data that's like behind that in the real workday tenant and i would love
to see a bug hunter find that and share it it would really um it would bring me joy so yeah that would
be huge work that would be huge yeah lots of lots of cool targets out there man lots of cool targets
in the sas space so aaron thank you for giving us your methodology and some of your your thoughts on
these uh sasses that you've pwned um yeah really appreciate it man great episode any uh any closing
thoughts uh joseph or is that about it no just thank you so much aaron it's a pleasure working with you and
uh hopefully we can collab on stuff going forward so yeah anything you want to shout out aaron uh
well joseph i miss you at up on me so that's the first thing like come back please um yeah i'd
actually love to give a shout out to my company at up omni i'm not being hate to say that uh just
because i have learned so much about sas security from working there um really really knowledgeable
group of people uh experts in their field coming from actually coming from salesforce and actually
coming from these organizations so um yeah i i wouldn't be the the kind of sas hacker that i am
today with that uh the folks over there so big shout out to those guys go follow aaron's blog and his uh
his twitter slash x account as well yeah yeah it's uh conspiracy proof on x and enumerated.ie for the
blog all right i think that's a wrap thanks gentlemen peace peace and that's a wrap on this episode of
critical thinking thanks so much for listening and if you want more critical thinking content
head over to ctbb.show discord join the discord there's lots of great conversations and chats going
on over there and if you want to support the show there's the discord subscriber tiers which give you
access to master classes amas hack alongs exclusive scripts and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there